we talk about how you sold your first
screenplay what was it okay now I had
writing television I had been writing
episodic television and getting
assignments and things but I wasn't
thinking on staff on a show I it was
hard to do it was at the time where they
gave out more freelance assignments on
TV shows than they do now but still the
whole point was to get on staff on a
show and I was just finding that that
that wasn't the so the direction
everything was moving in so I decided to
start writing screenplays because I
always loved movies and that's kind of
what I started off wanting to do but I
felt TV would be kind of a good way to
enter the business and and and something
a little more accessible which I think
it was but I started just writing a
screenplay so I took a couple of courses
about writing a screenplay I took a
great classical writers bootcamp which I
ended up teaching for a long time a few
years after I took it and I never wrote
a few scripts and sort of got on the I
think they I got they got attention if
you've got option things happen and then
ultimately I just kept writing spec
screenplays you know I mean they you
have to keep writing if you know if
you're not getting assignment work and
you have the time to write you know to
write on spec you have to keep cranking
things out so at that particular point
in in the movie business a lot of this
was a little bit after the big million
dollar spec sales and all of that where
you know like everything was selling but
as I missed that way but but but high
concept comedies were kind of in you
know they were you could sell them you
know they had to be good that'd be a
good idea but they were saleable now
it's different I mean now it's in
studios and making fewer of them it's
harder to sell those now unless it's
like a big star attached to it but back
then it was it was just that was just
kind of like the bread and butter and
everybody wanted those scripts so I
wrote a script called Manhattan Transfer
which was about a New York radio shrink
sort of a shock jock of a radio shrink
who on one day starts starts taking on
the neuroses of all of his callers at
the time that he's making the very week
he's making the leap from local radio to
national television as a shrink as a you
know as a
as TV shrink and and it's just the story
of how it gets through this period of
time and he hooks up with his old old
graduate school girlfriend who turned
that to be his young son school
psychologist and she can help some as a
psychologist on this journey of getting
through this crazy week when he's taken
on the transference of all of the all of
his clients neuroses in his whole his
whole thing as the shock jock is
neuroses are all in your head there is
no such thing and now he's kind of and
he's cursed by the ghost of Sigmund
Freud and he comes to him in middle of
the night and says you know you're doing
you're really hurting people by your
saying that there's no such thing as
neuroses so you're going to start
feeling everything that all your people
are feeling and that you've been mocking
all this time and then he wakes up and
he start it starts to happen and it's a
very very funny description a very funny
story and it was ultimately blocked by
at the time by Davis Entertainment for
20th Century Fox and I worked with Fox
and Davis developing the script I did
drafts of different drafts of the script
they kept reaction again ultimately it
just sort of it just sort of never never
went anywhere after that so I got it
back but it's a great you know big broad
character comedy so I'm hoping one day
it'll find its place but that was the
first the first the first sale and very
shortly after that I had my second sale
which was just kind of amazing that it
all happened at once it was a an
independent film was a spec script that
I wrote called who's on first
it was a romantic comedy and it was
ultimately bought by an independent film
company and they made the film under the
title if you only knew and so like
between and within like one year or six
months or something I was able to sell
these two scripts the film that was made
it took a little while to get made took
a few years over the course of a few
years to get made and lilies but but
yeah that was that was really kind of a
fun beginning and the whole point is
when you sell something is to be able to
parlay that into selling something else
so I got a lot of meetings at the time
and you know it I sort of got on the
radar of things and you try to work that
and I try to get other work from it and
all of that so it was good when you
talked about the previously having these
scripts that you've written but they
sort of in their fifth live why
you know they what are you doing to know
if it's the right time you said it's
sort of whatever's out in the ether are
you looking through the news everyone
it's more general sense but I mean I
think for example this script Manhattan
Transfer which I ended up changing the
title to reverse psychology over time
you know there are different places now
that that will make maybe it's not a
feature film maybe it's you know a movie
for crackle or some you know some you
know internet or screaming service that
they make that's starting to produce
their own comedies yeah there's that
whole concept like what what else is out
there where you can now sell this kind
of material and you know just updated
for you know for where we are today
there's that I wrote a script a long
time ago called red hot mamas which is
about three women of a certain age
single women of a certain age who end up
winning a trip to a Caribbean island and
they take the trip together not
realizing that they're landing their
smack in the middle of college Spring
Break and it's a story about how these
these women in their late forties end up
end up being pursued by these college
guys or 20 and you know it's a little
American Pie edge whatever but that that
was it you know the funny script you
know didn't sell back then now there's
this whole you know big proliferation of
you know women's comedies broad women's
comedies from bridesmaids to bad moms
they're making bad moms Christmas coming
up this year there's a movie that was at
Sundance I think called mom's lunch out
something that moms great lunch or
something that got a lot of attention so
we're out again with red hot mamas we've
retitled it milk and and and what I did
was I rewrote it a little bit ago and I
kind of cut the--' got the young guys a
bit and sort of amped up the women's
roles more so it's really really the
women's story the guys are there the
story is similar but I kind of I kind of
really focused on the women more and did
more work on them and we're going out
with what was it again you know trying
to get interested in it because because
fun women's women's comedies women
empowerment comedies women of a certain
age you know
doing crazy things there's a market for
it now so there's that kind of thing so
that that was something that evolved
over over time you know bridesmaids was
just you know it could have been a
one-off and it turned out to be
something that really affected and
changed you know the film business in a
way the comedy business and certainly
Melissa McCarthy from that she kind of
shakes you changed a bit of the face of
comedy what's with what studios are
making you know what comes to comedy you
know so so there's a new you know so
there's that you know there's that that
that kind of thing that's at the
zeitgeist so basically oh sometimes you
know if it's if it's based on a true
story
you know sometimes like I have the
rights to a book called rescuing Riley
which is about as true story about a man
who rescues a dog from a canyon and how
he saves the dog's life and how the dog
kind of saves his life emotionally as a
result of it so it's a wonderful book
and we've been out with the trying to
get it set up and all of that and then a
dog's purpose was coming out and I said
to my agent you know dogs purpose is is
I read the book it's a you know a great
book and if the film would be good I had
a feeling would do well get a lot of
attention I said everybody's going to be
looking for their dog movie you know
this might be a good time to really put
a push on rescuing Riley so it's out
there again in a bigger way that's that
kind of thing you know because it is a
roller coaster and you never know I mean
some scripts that I've written some
screenplays they're dated and you know
the topic just doesn't work anymore and
you know you just put them aside
you